dollars i think bitcoin is at this point
is charlie the guy who
uh was running silk road
no oh that was ross ulbricht ross
allegedly right allegedly okay is that
the guy you were telling me about
who yeah uh we were talking about on the
phone
i think so what's his story so he was in
like a library or something
yes that was crazy uh so the silk road
there's been many
versions after him yeah because
i guess it's a popular idea but
basically that's why bitcoin has such a
bad rap to it because people think about
buying drugs or
buying organs or buying whatever
whatever yeah human trafficking
so basically ross and or
people around ross or a group of people
built this thing
in 2000 probably 11 or
10 maybe 2010
yeah no no it's probably 2011 or 12.
they built
this thing called the silk road it ran
on the dark web right
which is uh sort of a
area of the internet that you can't
really access unless you
know how to get there but um
the is basically ebay for
with but you use bitcoin and you could
list anything on there
so while one could easily sell shirts or
tchotchkes or knitted sweaters um
i'd say there was a large amount of uh
drug sales on the silk road and it was
brought the attention of some political
folks
i think the famous video was like chuck
schumer
who is like looking at it it was like a
news story and chuck schumer was like
scrolling he's like oh my god you can
buy anything on here
and that's when they exploded like
that's when it became like uh
that was like huge advertising for them
people were like oh wait i can do what
yeah so uh yeah you went on uh silk road
and uh you could buy basically you'd pay
for it with bitcoin
and then it would get mailed to you you
know so just like ebay
except for you know anything anything
basically
it was free market right and people
didn't like it
well no people loved it the government
didn't like it the government
um so the the fbi started investigating
and figured out and actually part of the
i think one of the ways that they were
able to track
it to him is he had posted a bitcoin
address
at some point uh in a forum
to like for somebody to send money to
him
and uh he he went by the handle of the
dread private dread pirate roberts
dpr and uh
and so this uh that was able to link
they were able to then link it to link
that address to one of the silk road
addresses
and then to that username and then just
had to figure out who the username was
and a lot of people speculate that he
may have not been
like the only guy running but he was
just maybe an admin or something he
definitely was involved
as far as we can tell
but he uh so they figured out who he was
and yeah they they did a sting operation
on him
and they did it in a public library he
would go to a public library library to
work and
so the big thing when you're dealing
with somebody who's you're trying to
investigate or get their
you know any incriminating evidence that
may be on their computer right
but he's a fairly knowledgeable crypto
security guy
so like a lot of if you're in a position
like him where
he may or may not be like favorable to
the government
uh under investigation or something
you might like have a thing where if you
do a certain key press on your computer
it encrypts your whole computer or if
you close your lid
you know you it's encrypted and it's
locked so they can't get into it
um so they set up this
thing where this male and female fbi
agent pretended to get into a fight
at in the library like right they were
like
right near him and the fight was like
escalated to a point where he felt like
he needed to get involved so what he did
is he sat
his laptop down open and stood up
to go approach them or something and
that's the moment where they
basically pounced and she the dude moved
to restrain him and then
the girl went and threw this thumb drive
thing in his computer that would keep
keep it from shutting down and start
downloading everything off of it
what yeah they have these little it's
like a little
it's just like a little it's like a
thumb drive that just sucks everything
out of the computer yeah basically
it's also got like a mouse wiggler in it
so basically like if like
so it won't let the laptop go idle you
just keep wiggling the mouse or
something so it keeps
and then they see how they got him and
then they
uh leveled all these crazy charges on
him
um the to this day
when i talked to people at russell burke
they're like oh yeah isn't that a guy
that did murder for hire
on the silk road there was a murder for
a higher charge
placed on him as this long list of
charges and one of them was murder for
hire and that's the one that made like
all the headlines
that he basically was trying to have
somebody off and pay them a bitcoin you
know and this thing but
but before the trial even started like
that was completely dropped like there
was
it was completely baseless no no basis
in fact whatsoever
and but it's enough to like why did they
come up with that why did they say that
to smear him really yeah i think nobody
like tried to try to
pay somebody on silk road as like a
hitman there's the old saying that you
know
uh that a lie can go around the world
twice before the truth gets its shoes on
you know that's fine so like you know
the redaction of that
or the fact that those charges are
dropped isn't news
but the charges themselves are are good
news you know what i mean
like like
posting that this kid was doing murder
for hire stuff
you know makes sells newspapers but like
saying oh that was retracted like a year
later or
doesn't but either way they what they
got him for
well maybe they said that maybe they
said that like somebody
did like on silk road tried to hire a
hitman
to commit a murder on his platform no
they were sitting so therefore he's
guilty
he said that he did it himself that was
the that was the implication was he did
it himself
okay but do you know do you know
do you know do you know if that was
something that happened on celebration i
don't think it did
happen on silk road no it's not really
uh
like i don't know how you would
advertise like
murder i mean would you just say i don't
know if you put up a posting like hey
i'll
kill people for you i don't know
enforcer or like i don't think i think
they did have that and i think they did
have terms of service
i'm not an expert on it did they did
have terms of service i'm pretty sure
that would have been outside
and they might have flagged it or
something yeah that's kind of flagged it
okay
so i don't i don't think that actually
was happening on silk road
and uh he definitely was not
involved in it personally so but that
that kind of helped soil his reputation
though
and then i mean basically he was made
example of i think they they hit him
with
like kingpin charges for for all the
drug
stuff uh it resulted in the arrests of a
bunch of
people who were actually dealing drugs
um
because they were able to tie them tie
their addresses to them personally
through
like chain analysis or something they
made mistakes
missteps somewhere along the way to to
compromise their identities
on the blockchain and they so they made
several arrests on the
uh of actual drug dealers but
to my knowledge i don't think ross ever
dealt any drugs he just ran the platform
you know
right so and what he made him he hit
like a middleman fee on turn to the
transactions
and he was also the escrow agent so like
um now if you send money to somebody uh
you have paypal right and paypal um
basically kind of holds the money until
you try to make sure and then make sure
that you send the goods right
so they would act as like uh an escrow
agent so the the bitcoin they would hold
the bitcoin
and then release it once it was
delivered safely you know
to the so actually they were holding a
lot of bitcoin when
it was seized so a lot of people who are
using the platform lost a lot of bitcoin
to the government
and they they i guess were able to
i don't know if it was on his laptop or
if via his laptop they're
able to get access to other servers but
they uh
it was a lot of bitcoin it was like six
six hundred thousand
bitcoin sixty sixty thousand something
like that bitcoin
that was on there it was millions of
dollars and they sent it out in uh
increments that i don't know what it is
on the phone but if you know
uh on a touchdown phone you got the
numbers that line up with the
or the the letters that line up like in
the old days if you wanted to text you'd
do like
uh you know like two let's see like so
i can't do it in my head but like you
know two one three would would like
spell a word
it's like each letter had three each
number had three
letters attached like five eight 008
upside down is boobs
no not like that like oh uh if you
anyhow
it was i think it was like see
one is a b c two is um
a touchstone phone two is uh oh i see
that right okay so it was yeah i want to
say it was
it was two one they sent it they sent it
out in increments
that was two one
three or four two one four and it was it
was the
fbi like if you typed it into a photo of
the fbi and they so they sent it out of
the wall
out of the ross albrecht wallet in those
increments that made
fbi so it was like 100 transactions
wow of that amount to different wallets
of the and then the government auctioned
him off a couple years later
really yeah do you know what the current
status of his
truck his case is yeah it's pretty sad
so he got
uh like i said level like he had kingpin
charges
put on him so like i could use a drug
kingpin and he got a double life
sentence
so he's in jail forever they've appealed
it
a double life sentence yeah for running
a website where people can sell drugs he
was like 20
like five or 26 when this all happened
so yeah so he's got a double life
sentence his mom who's a great person
his name her name's lynn
if you go to freeross.org you can find
a bunch of information about him and his
case she runs freeross.org
she's spoken at my meetup before a
couple years ago
and you know she basically
i mean she's his mom so of course but
she talks about
they've done they've appealed it all the
way to the supreme court and basically
his only hope now is a presidential
pardon
always got left yeah it's presidential
party so there's so free roster org
they're trying to do like petitions and
stuff to
how old was when he went in what's that
how old was he when he
went into his 20s
yeah i'm pretty sure he was like 25 26
something like that
you know a couple years out of college
and
you know she says he's just an
idealistic
idealist yeah kid you know he just
wanted to create this marketplace to
facilitate trade whatever he wasn't like
trying to be a drug kingpin or ruin
people's lives or anything like that or
um but yeah that's what you get for
building certain websites is double life
sentences
so it's pretty bad uh so yeah but
there's more silk road like there's more
go ahead what we're saying just say
anybody listening go to freeross.org and
check out his story and uh
what you can do to help yeah now aren't
there
other websites like silk road out there
now
like dark web style websites where you
can buy it yeah as soon as that silk
road went down somebody built another
one right and that one
that one scammed everybody like uh
the second one that was built yeah once
they got to a certain
critical mass you know because they were
acting as an escrow agent
as well so instead of the fbi stealing
all their money
uh stealing all the users money like the
original silk road this guy just once he
got to a certain amount of bitcoin that
he had
he just shut everything down and took
the money and ran
geez but yeah since then there've been
tons
um people that makes different i mean
it's just
it was a good idea or a popular idea a
lot of traction so
and you think about it you know if you
if you're into doing drugs or whatever
uh it's a pretty safe way of acquiring i
know that there's i mean i had a friend
of mine in college who
he got like carjacked and beat up once
just trying to get
um some drugs from some neighborhood
once oh you mean like on the streets
yeah he went to the wrong neighborhood
and they stole his car it had his guitar
his civic guitar in the back seat
yeah he stole his car and beat him up
god damn dude
and uh he was just trying to buy some
weed i think what where was he
it was in augusta georgia okay yeah so
um so it's dangerous so i mean it's uh
for all parties involved you know just
paying some money and getting it in the
mail
if it's just something you're you know
it's just for your own recreational
purposes and whatever and
you know it's your body you can screw it
up however you want or or
become enlightened however you look at
it yeah right
they need to legalize drug man it makes
everything so much better
all drugs